across the country
ordinary americans from all walks of
life are taking whatever measures
necessary to prepare
i'm preparing my family for the total
destruction of the power grid
the yellowstone super volcano a
financial collapse
and protect themselves and survival is
the goal
it's into the spider hole fast fast fast
fast
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
what i'm gonna use like this
next we go inside the lives of four
committed preppers
who have devised extensive plans we have
enough for about eight people for three
years
gone to great lengths oh poison them or
cut their throats in their sleep or
something like that and made huge
personal sacrifices to ensure their very
survival
my knees broke my back's broke my hands
broke
uh the only thing that still works on me
is my mouth
the experts will assess their extreme
preps and decide if they have what it
takes
to face armageddon here's to the end of
the world
and to survive this is doomsday
preppers
[Music]
david sardi is a disabled truck driver
living outside of nashville tennessee
for 20 years his job took him to every
corner of the united states
but now his life's work is at home he's
a prepper
[Music]
i'm preparing for an electromagnetic
pulse that will disable the
transportation system
of the united states
an electromagnetic pulse or an emp is a
sudden burst of energy that can take out
any electrical appliance
a nationwide emp can be caused by a
solar flare
a sudden release of energy from the sun
an emp
only takes a millisecond
your television will go off the car
would stall
all your lights would go out it would be
like somebody
instantly flipped a switch on the world
in 1859
an emp in the form of a solar flare hit
the united states and europe
nicknamed the carrington event it caused
an almost worldwide failure of the
telegraph system
one of the few electronic technologies
of the day
in some places it was so powerful it
actually started
fires and burnt the wires in two
could you even imagine what it would do
today
with all the wires that are strung all
over the place
we know that the natural one will happen
again
if a similar emp hit today scientists
believe that it could take
over a year to repair america's damaged
electrical grid
to stay ahead of the game david monitors
the sun's activity on a daily basis
checking for the warning signs
associated with massive solar flares
yeah this is where one of those
emp events would come from this is live
right now the last few days
it's putting out a lot of flares but
right now we're getting a lot of
electrical interference if one of those
pops out at
earth that's when things go bad
some people think i'm obsessed about
prepping but you know i hope they're
right
i hope they think i hope i am crazy i
hope nothing happens
you know that would be the greatest
thing in the world
all right you're gonna lose my eyes
folks
don't i look cool a fat tom cruise
spending 20 years on the road as a
trucker has given david an insight into
just how bad the effects of an emp would
be
the trucking industry is what this
country lives on
there's not one thing one thing that you
don't touch
see hear and eat that does not come on a
truck
[Music]
all the trucks are computerized and an
electromagnetic pulse
would fry the computer in those trucks
just like it would fry the computers in
most all your cars
this is the truck computer don't look
like much that controls
all the stuff for the truck without that
this one here wouldn't run at all
gauges in there fuel sensors i call it
the achilles heel
of the nation's trucking fleet just
three days without a working
transportation system
would leave america's grocery stores
empty
back at his farm david adds the shelled
corn to his doomsday stores
all stashed for the long term in 208
liter containers
i have enough food and dry grains
for one year for seven people now this
isn't
nothing that you're gonna love to eat
it's basically cornbread
with beans put these hand warmers in
there they're the same thing as oxygen
absorbers
push out as much air as you can hand
warmers contain fine iron filings that
can absorb oxygen from the air
when placed in a sealed bag they can
eliminate mold and pests
that rely on oxygen to survive 20 years
30 years
that's good i'll be pushing up daisies
before that goes bad
what david can't store he plans to grow
on his farm
intent on making it the perfect location
to sit out doomsday
i'm in a bugat location we can produce
more food than we can eat here so
technically i have an
unlimited supply
[Music]
so while all of y'all in new york are
eating romaine noodles
around here we're going to be eating a
lot of ribeye steak and t-bones
approximately three days after an
electromagnetic pulse
the panic would have done already hit
and most everybody would have cleaned
out the grocery stores
within three weeks you're gonna have the
first variety
because people when they get hungry
they're gonna try
to take other people's food away from
them
to stave off hungry masses david has a
three-stage security plan in
place
i've got several extra rolls of barbed
wire
then you have these yappy little dogs if
the
person has gone through all the trouble
to get through the barbed wire
and try to take on the dogs finally the
last line of defense
is this
every gun in this house is loaded
i'm a decent shot i was a lot better
i used to be able to shoot the wings off
of nat's ass at 100 yards
not too bad for a fat guy david has
taken his expertise to the small screen
all right all you youtubers he regularly
preaches the prepping gospel
to a large online audience so we're
gonna pour that into the ceramic filter
he covers everything from water
filtration dirty water
has turned into clean water
to homemade antibiotics so what i'm
going to do is show you
how to make your own antibiotics thank
you very much
communication is survival for david and
he has no intention of giving it up for
an apocalypse
when there's an emergency the value of
communication is
fairly basic i mean if you don't know
where
the help is what good is it going to be
you have to have information to know
where it is
all right ki4lwa i just wanted to tell
you
you picked the right subject about emp
tonight
congratulations
[Applause]
amateur or ham radio allows david to
communicate with millions of other ham
operators worldwide using only existing
radio frequencies in the air
it requires no phone lines no internet
and can be run completely on battery or
solar power
whiskey charlie 2 victor uh be back in a
few
it's kind of neat to be able to talk to
somebody not using any of the
infrastructure
it's something i can give back to the
community my knees broke my back's broke
my hands broke
uh the only thing that still works on me
is my mouth that goes a mile a minute
you know it's like i have a little
briggs and stratton motor in there
even though a ham radio would work after
an emp
it still needs to be protected during an
enp
and to keep his prized possession safe
david is building
a faraday cage a faraday cage
is a metal container that encloses
the item completely in a conductive
material by creating a seamless metal
surface that electricity would run along
but not through
anything inside the faraday cage would
be protected from the electrical surge
caused by an emp we're not done yet but
this all has to be sealed up and it's
going to be wrapped in metal
all the way around if i was inside i
could close the door
and lightning bolts could strike and i
wouldn't even know they were hitting me
i would probably give it a few days
before i even unpacked my radios from
their cages
and then i would turn them on and scan
the frequencies
listening for other amateur radio
operators
there are many people that believe that
they can just become hermits
and that's fine and dandy but if you
want to rebuild society
you need to communicate if you don't
know where
the help is what good is it going to be
you have to have information to know
where it is
the consultants at practical preppers
are impressed by your ability to grow
and store food
and your communication systems will help
you to build back your community
yes one of the reasons i got into
amateur radio is for emergency
communications
even though i'm in bad health there's
still things that i can do
as long as i'm here i'm going to do my
best to help others but your health
is your biggest obstacle to survival
without the physical strength to 10
crops and chop wood
you will need outside help in surviving
an emp
i've been focusing on my health i've
come to a point right now where
it's going to take surgery but it is
what it is
since the national geographic special
people were filming here
my health has not changed if anything it
may got worse
unless unless something happens that i
can
afford the surgery i don't have much
hope in that
what are the odds of an emp actually
occurring extremely rare and
unpredictable
massive solar storms happen about every
150 years
carrington-sized events which could take
years to recover from
happen every 500 years or so
[Music]
in the salt lake city suburb of orem
utah colleen bishop has earned a
reputation for being able to whip up
gourmet cuisine
in a flash and what the bubbly housewife
is also known for
is i am preparing for a financial
collapse
which will result in the end of the
world as we know it
i believe that there will be a colossal
financial collapse i believe we're on
the precipice of that right now
the mortgage industry the currency value
wall street
unemployment etc etc it's all going to
come into
play as the perfect storm we have a
great deal of foreign debt that could be
turned over
and flooded back into the system at any
time there will be a day reckoning and
when that happens
the financial collapse will take a
matter of hours before it impacts us
right here in this nation
i used to run a multi-million dollar
business
i had my bling that my husband gave me
every christmas
now the kind of bling that i asked santa
claus for is typically the type of bling
you'll see on a pressure cooker or a
solar oven
if we find ourselves in a world where
there's been a financial collapse
and it's very likely grocery stores will
be empty
i think i might be eating a little
differently than other preppers because
i'm a foodie
everything i have i have for full flavor
and gourmet foods
if the world comes to an end i may be
eating rice and beans but they will be
some
kicking rice and beans i'll be eating
more things like
beef stroganoff chicken poppy seed
casserole cocoa van
four cheese italian risotto i'll be
eating some good stuff
under a doomsday scenario i'll be the
only one standing there who has another
hundred pounds
to lose everybody else will be skin and
bones
so what are we looking at then wheat
wise yeah oh we've probably got
uh about three thousand pounds between
the two of us something like colleen and
her husband scott
foresee a day when money is so worthless
that fuel and groceries
become luxury items coco has gone up
300 percent since last christmas
my worst case scenario is the value of
the dollar is brought down to
four cents you believe these are 25
cents
to prepare for a society where a carton
of milk might become prohibitively
expensive
colleen and her husband spend six to
eight hours a day prepping and
stockpiling enough food and water
to last them for years this is where
we store all of our yummy freeze-dried
and dehydrated foods
just this closet alone we have enough
for about eight people
for three years a protein room we're
running out of room for the
canned chicken this one won't fit
uh there's meat stored all over the
place it's like oops excuse me don't
step on the meat
a modified guest bedroom eight 55 gallon
barrels of water what have you done to
my guest bedroom honey it's a water bed
no i'm not getting up on there
and a comfort room so a lot of people
think that this room is a little bit
overkill
this is where i store all the comforts
such as chocolate
brownie mixes and toilet paper all of
our preparedness supplies that we have
in the home presently
um probably have a retail value of over
a hundred thousand dollars
just so you know i tallied the milk and
we're looking at 700 gallons but i
really want that to be up to 900. i
think they've got a sale coming up on
that too so now would be a good time for
that it's the only time
my wife does like to store a lot of food
i'm grateful for a wife that
likes to and is good at cooking okay
it's something that gives you an edge in
a doomsday scenario
i might add just a couple pats of butter
because batter always makes uh the sauce
the fact of the matter is i'd go back
into a burning house for my cookbooks
i watch a lot of cooking shows in order
to give me great inspiration for gourmet
dishes from
shelf stable foods it is not tough to
make gourmet menus
out of shelf stable foods the only
tricky part is knowing how to make a
food
shelf stable colleen fears that
electricity costs will skyrocket
and she won't be able to rely on her
refrigerator consequently
she treats her perishable foods so they
will stay fresh for years
so we're actually preserving eggs today
she is teaching her friend barb
food preservation tricks put a little
bit of mineral oil on your hands
and then slather it all over the egg
which is basically mimicking how they
already come out of the hen
not allowing oxygen to get through this
goes fast
it does when i get a killer deal on eggs
like 50 cents or 75 cents a dozen
i can buy a whole lot of them and i can
store them in a cool dry place without
them going bad
they will sit tight for about uh 9 to 12
months
there we go so i'm actually dipping hot
cheese wax
over hard cheeses all you do is just dip
it in here nice and easy
they continue to age but you don't have
to have refrigeration
these will keep for 20 to 25 years
that's great
in the event of a financial collapse i
suspect that a lot of people are gonna
have to just eat that
nasty powdered stuff not me i am having
swiss cheese on
homemade naan bread
there we're running out of room in here
hon a fortified pantry isn't colleen's
only defense against a catastrophic
financial collapse
if her fears are realized she's prepared
to fight back
so you're never more than 20 feet away
from a firearm in this house
one example is a small firearm and a
number 10 can of peas
and i remember that because it's my pee
shooter so this is my
everyday kind of weapon they don't make
cans quite big enough for my doomsday
weapons
and we get all the peas off and it's not
about protecting your food
it's about protecting your life your
comfort and even your virtue
my husband and i focus a great deal on
what we call our bug
in plan where things are so awful
outside that you really don't want to go
anywhere
in a doomsday financial collapse
scenario
we would be staying put exactly where we
are tonight the bishops practice
sweeping the house for intruders
who may attempt to loot their food
supplies
[Music]
being able to walk through your home
without the lights on which you may not
have
is critical knowing the layout of your
home
gives you a significant advantage
i navigate this house in the dark even
better than i navigate my own town with
a gps system
we feel confident that we could take
care of any potential invader
we chose morse code as one of our
communication strategies because we were
watching one of the charlie angels
movies
and they're like doing morse code on
each other's hands in the dark so that
they know what their next
kickbutt move is anyway so we thought
that would be a good idea so we started
using that
i think having the alternative
communication measures will be very
important
you don't always want to turn your hand
and the element of surprise is one of
the biggest assets that you have
we want to have more than one
communication means
and so another strategy is learning to
be fluent in tagalog
hindi say young they speak tagalog in
the philippines it is a rare language
so it's not likely that we run into
someone who will be fluent in that as
well
i think there are a lot of people that
would think that
the extent that my wife and i go to is
probably
let's say insane
that will change certainly in a doomsday
scenario
if society crumbles colleen and scott
plan on being a resource for others
out but they won't be able to defend
everything
so it's right behind the adam's apple
so instead they are teaching their
community
how to survive
[Music]
colleen is so passionate about the
importance of self-defense
she has left her corporate job to teach
ordinary housewives
how to protect themselves
she provides hands-on training including
a quick draw shooting class for women
we'll have women coming in having never
even fired a gun before
and we will be able to teach them this
skill by the end of our class
you should just see their faces
it makes such a difference for them to
know that they can take care of
themselves
the quick draw is a self-defense
technique you don't have time to say
oh mr bad guy will you please get in my
line of sight
you're going to breathe in and then
you're going gonna breathe out as you
extend
out
there you go and then you do the dance
and if she runs out of bullets she is
also an expert in
self-defense history has shown us again
and again and again that when the
society collapses then you have great
amounts of violence
specifically targeting women
the first mistake they will make is to
underestimate
your ability to fight back i push my
foot up to the ceiling i don't need to
be strong
women that actually take the time to
learn this technique they have
mentally empowered themselves so that
they actually have a better chance of
avoiding rape
okay right exactly so it's right behind
the adam's apple
are you allowed to hurt maimer kill
someone who wants to rape you
okay awesome you want to dig your thumbs
in to his eyes
please don't pull out my husband's eyes
okay
okay this will crack or crush bone you
want a top to bottom
stripe
all right so that wraps up our training
for today
in the interest of strengthening our
preparedness community so that we can
all be safe and strong
i'm inviting you over to my house this
evening for a fabulous dinner party
i am so excited about tonight's dinner
party i'm not gonna make a single dish
with anything from the refrigerator or
from the freezer
perky fabulous i don't think most people
would think of this as doomsday cooking
she's fabulous colleen and scott are the
star preppers in
my estimation
welcome everybody to this evening's
preparedness pro dinner party
everything you can make from shelf
stable food
i don't want you to ever think of food
storage and curl up your lip like
ever again okay wow this is amazing
i've had a deviled egg with almonds
before these must be
salmon cakes right
how old are these eggs they're about
seven eight months so i'll do this and
tell my kids at thanksgiving that
they're nine month old eggs
there you go here's to
eating well at the end of the world
[Music]
the experts have concluded that your
food storage is excellent
and commend you for developing a varied
cooking plan and for sharing this
knowledge with your community
your self-defense strategies will also
serve you well in case of a societal
breakdown due to economic collapse
it is likely that others will look to
you for help in dangerous times
we expect people to turn to us in times
of crisis in a doomsday
type scenario and we're not naive we are
prepared for
both type of people who might want to
come
however while your stored water is a
good start
it is inadequate for a long-term bug-in
you can only survive three days without
water
at the bare minimum we recommend you
install a rain catching system
so you can replenish your water supply
um i'd say we've covered that bare
minimum several times over haven't we
backups to backups we don't necessarily
reveal all our cards
since um we wrapped up the show
um we have added to those reserves both
in terms of water and in terms of
options for fuel and power
so i think we're sitting just fine and
the
changes that we will make will be done
because of our continual efforts in
preparedness
what are the odds of a financial
collapse actually occurring
while hyperinflation and severe
depressions have occurred in major
economies in the past
most economists do not believe the
united states is currently at risk
kathy harrison is a new england liberal
living the idyllic country life
she plays soccer with her kids cooks
homemade meals for her family
and loves to garden except
they call me the doris day of doom
because i'm preparing for a black swan
event
like a catastrophic new madrid
earthquake
black swan events are those events that
come out of nowhere we often say oh i
didn't see that one coming but they have
the potential
to completely change the way we live our
lives kathy thinks the next black swan
will come in the form of a catastrophic
earthquake along the 200 kilometer long
new madrid seismic zone
in the central united states the new
madrid fault covers
seven states it has actually let go
twice before there was a big
earthquake in 1811. from december 1811
to march 1812 there were thousands of
quakes in the new madrid zone
including around 20 that were magnitude
6.5 or larger
now things would be totally different we
have major cities on that fault zone
we have nuclear power plants we have
communications that
have to cross that it would effectively
cut our country into two pieces
millions of trucks crossed the new
madrid seismic zone every year
carrying food and other supplies if the
truck stopped running we'd be out of
food in three days
i'm prepared for that we have chosen a
place to live that can be
fairly self-sufficient in terms of food
water
and heat we have enough carrots here we
could probably feed the whole
neighborhood
kathy and her husband bruce grow most of
their family's food
in their backyard i am the supporter of
the doris day of doom would you think
about adding
more of those currents scattered in with
the flowers
that might be a good idea i wouldn't say
prepping his obsession i would say is
just the way we live
we're growing kale and peppers all of
these tomatoes we grew from seed that we
saved from our tomatoes from last year
i never have to worry about buying seed
if there's ever a supply disruption i'm
good
we grow a lot of tomatoes i probably put
up about a hundred yards of sauce a year
tomatoes are the only things that kathy
preserves in a jar
in fact she pretty much cans everything
in sight
i probably have
700 cans down in the basement i have
several kinds of meat
chicken ground beef stew beef peaches
and pears
and beautiful cherries during canning
season i can easily spend six or eight
hours a day over my canner
all righty here we go there you go oh
here comes the steam
look at them boiling there you go this
is local grass-fed beef this meat will
stay good in this jar pretty much
indefinitely
if we have a power outage and our
freezers are down and everything this is
already cooked
i just have to heat it up and it's a
meal i could actually even eat a cold
out of the jar if i wanted to in a
magnitude 7.7 new madrid quake
it is estimated that over 2000 electric
oil and natural gas facilities would be
damaged
leaving millions across the country
without power i think we
think about electricity and it's this
magic stuff that's sort of
always there but think about what
happens when it's not always there
you can't pump gas you can't purchase
groceries you can't access money from
your bank account
if power goes down kathy and bruce have
prepared a plan b
a way to trade and barter for the goods
they need without
money you can't eat gold and you can't
eat silver
instead we have a number of things that
we could barter if we wanted to
we're gonna smoke them you want to take
the top off
bees have provided us with honey for
um thousands of years there was honey
found in the
tombs of egypt and the smoke keeps these
nice and gossip they'll stay right in
here
and behave themselves if i came down
here without smoking and opened these
hives they've been
all over us they've been really angry
honey can become very valuable it's one
of the only foods
that won't go bad you can store it
forever and ever and ever and ever
wow ah that's perfect
delicious in a grade down situation
those bees
become not just food for us but they
become
honey that we can barter for they become
candles they provide us with a base for
salves and creams for wounds or sores
those bees are the essence of resilience
for us
kathy and bruce are also building up a
bank of skills
that will give them complete
independence from mainstream society
my husband does the woodworking i like
to sew
get in there don't go too fast get in
the rhythm all right
all right all right we got it with wheat
i can grind it and turn it into good
bread for my family do you have muscles
can you do this i'll need
and you need oh look it i think i got it
i can chop a wood
i'm almost getting it i'm also thinking
about
who around me has a skill that i maybe
don't have so that we learn to depend on
each other kathy actively encourages her
entire community to ready themselves for
the coming doomsday
by including them in her prepping
activities
we're already in a sort of doomsday
event i mean
like is hitting the fan around us
our government is spending like hundreds
of billions of dollars a year
on weapons and the military like seems
like they're prepping
we've been very busy out collecting
apples for doing our cider pressing
how this process works is you throw them
into this hopper and it grinds them
you just keep turning and turning and
turning you see the cider comes out the
bottom here
after the cider has sat for a while
it will um you can turn it into hard
cider or whiskey
if a crisis happened we could barter
it'd be very very valuable
let me see how it is it's easy to feel a
little left out of the prepper community
if you live in new england and if you're
not
um fairly right-wing and conservative
politically but i
just don't spend my time worrying about
storing guns and ammunition
i think we're gonna get all this done
today because our security comes
not from stockpiling weapons but from
having
a community that respects each other
supports each other
and we have each other's backs keep
loading keep loading
some people say oh i just want to have
guns and frankly i think that's pretty
stupid
marauding bands come i'll show them how
much great food i've got i'll invite
them to some sort of feast and
charm them and then if i decide that
they could be useful and cooperative
great and otherwise i'll poison them or
cut their throats in their sleep or
something like that
[Music]
we have become a nation that expects to
be
taken care of we think that there is
always going to be some white knight and
a horse that comes into
to rescue us and more and more often
we're seeing that that just
is not the case hello dear i suppose
that there are some people
who do in fact think that i'm paranoid
and gloomy do me and why do i waste my
time thinking about this
but here's the reality because i've
spent a lot of time
preparing for the worst case scenario i
can afford
to be cheerful the rest of the time case
sarasara to the end of the world
by growing and preserving your own food
you have given yourself the ability to
survive without normal infrastructure
for many years
yeah i think so i think we've got enough
to really take care of ourselves
and our extended family i feel good
about it
you are well-rounded and self-sufficient
in community-based skills
but in a true nationwide disaster there
is likely to be widespread lawlessness
well it's um i'm really not worried
about that
we have a wonderful community that we
can fall on to support
you need to think about how you can
secure your location and learn to
protect your family with weapons that
you feel comfortable using
it's a place we really fall down there's
no question about it it just doesn't
really suit ethically who we are
it's been a few weeks since natgeo was
here to visit and we listened to what
they had to say but we've decided not to
change the way we prepare
at the end of the day the people who
stock up on guns and
the people who support resilient
communities can get together exchange
notes and we'll decide who fares the
best
what are the odds of a new madrid
earthquake actually occurring
the past three were about 500 years
apart but every 50 years
there's a 1 in 50 chance the big one
will hit
[Music]
dennis evers is a prop maker and
inventor who lives in a colorado ranch
like a typical family man he spends time
with his kids
grandkids and works to maintain the farm
except i'm prepping to protect my family
from global chaos brought on by
hyperinflation
as far as what i see on the horizon for
this country
are some pretty tough times and i
believe it's going to be a fairly
protracted
event the cause is the government
printing trillions of dollars when we
don't have it
to back it up if the economy collapses i
see a tremendous
shockwave going through our entire
society they're going to be a lot of
hungry people they're going to be
a lot of angry people
i'm concerned about how my family will
survive in a world where
food and basic needs are going to be
outrageously priced
if things go bad and the economy tanks
we're ready for it it's not going to be
a surprise we're not going to sit around
like millions of americans wondering
what happened or how it happened
we're simply going to spring into action
and survive
when it hits the fan each of my kids has
a job and an assignment and they know
what to do and how to do it
my oldest son tim is in charge of
hunting and security
my daughter jenny and her husband pat
are in charge of fuel
nate and betsy deal with communications
ricky knows how to weld and helps me
with engineering side of things
johnny's currently training to be an
emergency responder
[Music]
dennis believes that civilization will
devolve into a harsh dog-eat-dog world
once extreme hyperinflation hits
he and his wife sandy have stored
buckets of provisions and continued to
build up their stocks
by preserving massive quantities of
foodstuffs
as far as feeding your family canning is
probably one of the best things there is
and we've done it for years
sandy's in charge of food and she'll
spend days processing hundreds of quarts
of fruit
and it all entails a tremendous amount
of work i spend all
day canning there's days where all you
do is get up in the morning and start
canning and
until you go to bed at night people
might think what i do is excessive
but for our application it's not even as
much as i'd like to do
all right we finished this bushel of
peaches
and it made 21 quarts
these jarred peaches will last for years
when we're done with the canning we need
a place to put it and that's
under the beds so what i've done is
basically remove the box springs and put
boxes of canned goods
you're not supposed to stack the jars on
top of each other because it can break
the seal
so that's a lot when you do hundreds and
hundreds of jars
it takes up a lot of space so underneath
the bed is perfect stays cool
out of the way nobody messes with it
canning is only one of the three
labor-intensive methods used to make
large quantities of food last from six
months to a year
vacuum-sealed jars to preserve fruit a
homemade smoker to preserve meat and a
solar dehydrator that dennis invented
and constructed from scraps
which can be used to preserve either
we've invented some things here
at the ranch that helped feed the kids
almost no cost whatsoever
one of them is a solar dehydrator
the solar dehydrator operates by using
only the energy from the sun's rays
a bounty of fruit from the ranch is
ingeniously prepared by dennis
and at the end of the process the solar
dehydrator yields pounds and pounds of
long-lasting food
this will help me feed my family when
disaster hits by having
an abundant amount of food available
that really doesn't cost anything other
than the sun
the importance of delegating labor when
uh
it hits the fan is no person can do
everything i can only be so many places
at one time pat and jenny are my fuel
guys
and uh they take care of our wood needs
growing up when my family my dad
taught us kids all many different
capabilities that would enable us to be
more self-sufficient
firewood is a common fuel choice for
many preppers because of its easy
availability
so in order to be ready for
hyperinflation the evers routinely stock
their wood pile
we have a lot of implements around the
ranch here one of them is kong which is
a
homemade log splitter which we built for
absolutely nothing
pat and jenny use kong a lot because it
allows them to process a tremendous
amount of wood in a reasonable amount of
time
if the economy tanked and we had a
stockpile of our fuel which the boys are
cutting right now
we'd be able to keep the house warm we'd
be able to cook food boil water
and maintain some of the essentials that
people find
comforting and often take for granted
dennis believes the economy will crumble
and cause vital infrastructure
public works and homes to fall into
disrepair
in order to maintain their ranch's
infrastructure dennis has trained one of
his kids in a skill that might be in
short supply
my dad taught me pretty much everything
i have woodworking metal
plumbing electrical the economy of
collapsed any skill is a good skill
especially
metal working sturdy it's long lasting
it's just it's a good skill to know
ricky's a really good uh crafts person
she's capable of metal work and woodwork
and if i need help on my creations or
if we need to maintain them or build a
part ricky's got the capability to do it
she's there for me and she knows what to
do
dennis believes that if hyperinflation
occurs destructive life-threatening
situations
will be inescapable colorado had close
to 3
500 fires in 2010 so one of dennis's
youngest sons
has taken on the brave responsibility of
safeguarding the family
johnny's in fire training right now to
become a fireman which will be a nice
addition to have around in the event
this stuff hits the fan
dennis and johnny know that in order to
be ready johnny's training cannot stop
when he leaves the firehouse
ready set go
15 seconds [ __ ]
okay johnny hurry up coming on 45
seconds let's get going
coming on a minute buddy finish it up
where was that 2 15. you got to be
kidding me you're supposed to have it in
under a minute 30.
so i screwed up pretty big
the evers emergency food and water
supply far surpasses fema's three-day
recommendation for general disaster
preparedness
so they fear they will become a target
during an economic collapse
dennis has taken a more preventative
approach to ensuring their safety
nate and betsy are my tech team and
they're helping us install security and
communication devices here at the ranch
we're the gizmo couple and our job is to
deliver i.t to the family and that's
what we do
so essentially what we're doing here is
we're setting up a a security system for
motion detection we can place it
anywhere we'd like you know a driveway
a porch so for instance right now what
we're trying to do is
see what the distance on this device is
so you want to try it right here
bones are you ready yeah how's the
signal
perfect what's that 100 feet
at least yeah it's working good
but if intruders were able to infiltrate
the evers compound
dennis's son tim has been tasked with
the crucial duty of internal security
tim's a pretty good hunter and he's also
kind of kid that thinks outside the box
building bones and arrows
throwing tools timmy will be using his
unique skills
in the event the stuff hits the fan tim
has followed in his father's inventor
footsteps
and has found alternative uses for
commonplace construction items
pvc piping is ordinarily used in
plumbing but tim has uncovered
a more defensive use okay i'm gonna make
a bow out of pvc
the pvc has to be cut between four feet
and five feet for your bow
you have to tape the fiberglass rod
otherwise
it will crack and split if the economy
collapsed you could use this bow to hunt
small games
kitty cats dogs rats pigeons squirrels
doves and all that
the bow would be great for security
because it's quiet you wouldn't know
where the shot came from
the arrow came out the broadhead would
stay in continuing to move around
and may cause massive hemorrhaging which
is bleeding to death
most families get together for fun but
for this prepper family
practice makes perfect so every
wednesday the evers convene at the ranch
to discuss among other things their
survival plan
family night also gives us a chance to
check on other people's preps just to
see how they're doing
who can go get wood like maybe next
weekend or something amy called
she has some cedar but there's also a
bunch of old aspen and pine growth that
they're trying to clear out
the people that are going to survive
when it hits a fan
are people that have expected it have
prepared for it
have trained for it listen bring it here
we'll use kong we'll split it we could
knock it out in
two events and i believe they could
survive any catastrophe that's thrown
their way
i told all you kids that bottom line is
if it hits the fan
we need to just come together as a
family and look out for
you guys and look out for anybody else
that needs our help
it's just going to get really ugly and
it's going to be basically
every man for himself scenario yeah i
agree i know when it comes we'll all
come together here and
survive as a family that's all we can do
dennis if as you predicted extreme
hyperinflation causes global chaos in
your lifetime
your innovative food storage and
preparation methods will allow you and
your family
to eat for up to six months in an
economic meltdown
also the wide range of skills among your
family members will enable you to brave
a disaster situation i'm okay with both
those assessments
however you have a limited supply of
fuel the experts recommend you store
more fuel to survive a catastrophic
event
for an extended period of time i don't
agree with that i mean
if we run out of propane there's more
than enough wood
to last a really long time we all have
the skills to harvest and
process wood for fuel
it's been about a month since we
received the critique from your
specialist they're spot on yeah we need
more fuel even in order to bring in
firewood
you need fuel so it's just right now
it's too expensive we'll have to deal
with that
what are the odds of hyperinflation
actually occurring
while hyperinflation and severe
depressions have occurred in major
economies in the past
most economists do not believe the
united states is currently at risk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you